the middle Bistro said is a fixture in
european-style cafes and small
restaurants the set consists of a small
dining table in two chairs a bistro set
is also popular in homes with limited
outdoor space as there's usually enough
room for one on a balcony or small patio
the small restaurant bar known as the
Bistro originated in 19th century France
its iconic dining sets are still being
produced today in both traditional and
modern styles this French factory makes
them out of strips of flat steel with
rounded edges the first step is to
flatten the strip with pressure applying
rollers the steel then enters a press
which does three operations
simultaneously it cuts pieces to the
required length rounds their ends and
punches out holes where required these
are parts for the table legs
meanwhile this computer-guided machine
bends a half-inch steel rod into a
circle to form a ring that will support
the tabletop
[Music]
this table is collapsible allowing it to
fold flat for storage therefore two of
the legs are hinged a pen and not them
in the open position after putting
together the folding legs a worker
positions all the parts for the base on
an assembly fixture then he operates a
welding robot which welds all the
crossbars reinforcing the legs and the
legs to the ring it only takes about two
minutes to weld all these parts into a
folding table base
the manufacturers make the tabletop from
a square piece of sheet steel this
machine first shears off the corners
transforming the square into a circle
then it draws the edge upward to form a
half inch high rim on what will
eventually be the underside of the
tabletop it also cuts a hole in the
center for an umbrella pole and draws
that edge as well a worker mates the
tabletop to the folding base he inserts
the ring into the tabletops underside
rim then he opens the base and uses
spreading pliers to pull apart then but
the ends of the ring
[Music]
next he shields the underside of the
table with a scrap piece of metal and
welds the butted ends
[Music]
the table is now fully constructed
[Music]
the chair parts are cut on the same
press as the table legs each chair has
two long legs and two shorter legs
this machine simultaneously folds and
twists the two shorter ones and folds
the two longer ones the operator then
connects them with the crossbar
[Music]
the next operator places these connected
short legs in another machine
he adds washers to the protruding ends
of the crossbar that in the two long
chair legs connecting them lower down
with a crossbar the machine welds that
crossbar and forms each end of the other
crossbar into a rivet which creates the
folding point for this collapsible chair
frame the next operator places the frame
on another machine positioning three
holes on each side on two upright steel
pins he lays two steel slats for the
chair back on these pins then five more
for the seat on two identical pins
riveted to a pair of steel bars the
machine then forms two pins into rivets
attaching all the slats he then
assembles the seat to the frame
completing the construction of the chair
the tables and chairs go on to the paint
line the first station washes and dries
the furniture next a worker opens each
one to spray paint the articulation
points then automated nozzles paint the
rest this is industrial grade powder
paint known as powder coat a ten-minute
trip through a tunnel oven at 373
workers apply product information
stickers cushion protruding parts with
plastic covers and enclosed foot
protectors
The Bistro set is now ready just unfold
and unwind